E aí
e a morte é um tema que nunca desceu
muito Redonda para mim na minha vida Eu
tive três grandes moles da minha mãe do
meu pai da minha avó em todas elas Eu
fugir antes deixar na minha irmã de
peixes para segurar essa onda toda no
velório do meu pai eu tava super cansada
e eu disse que eu não iria no enterro e
a minha irmã mais velha falou temos que
enterrar nossos mortos essa coisa que eu
não deveria bem sobre a morte me fez
tentar entender melhor aí eu fiz dois
grandes cursos um de Dólares da Morte e
o outro de cuidados paliativos e lutam
na Fundação Elisabeth kluber-ross no
curso de dólar da Morte aprende as
coisas mais importantes da vida uma é
aprender a morrer é a outra é aprender a
não ter medo da morte foi um curso
sensacional Onde aconteceu a coisa mais
importante também na minha vida que foi
conseguir viver nessa
é o dia do meu velório todos os lutos
que tomam encalacrados e que a gente
encalacrar não percebe foi um dia de
muito choro de muita loucura de muita
profundidade alguns meses depois eu fui
para Itália que seria A Grande Viagem na
minha vida eu ia encontrar minhas raízes
na Itália e na Escócia ele vai ficar 17
dias na Europa mas tive que voltar
quatro dias depois por causa do
coronavírus e porque Itália fechar as
fronteiras eu achei muito estranho
porque assim geralmente universo Ele
explica as coisas que acontecem tem
sempre um sentido maior foi quando eu
descobri o sentido maior alguns dias
depois meu sobrinho de 30 anos teve um
AVC fulminante esperando o Uber na porta
do prédio Foi aí que eu entendi porque
que eu tinha voltado antes
é de um lado eu tinha as minhas irmãs
chorando assim alucinadamente que um som
gutural que eu nunca tinha visto antes
então a única coisa que eu pude fazer e
que eu aprendi foi o silêncio presente
para saber se alguém precisaria de
alguma coisa mas não tinha o que fazer
nessa hora e aí eu fui para casa da mãe
do meu sobrinho da Bia e aí ela é uma
outra situação porque a adrenalina tava
tomando o lugar porque elas precisavam
resolver as coisas práticas atestado de
óbito rabecão funerária Maquiagem essas
coisas todas que pegam a gente de
surpresa mas nesse momento eu lembrei de
umas coisas que aprendi no curso que é
sobre a beleza oculta parece uma coisa
estranha para se falar Beleza o pé
diante da Morte mas existe então eu
comecei a lembrar minha cunhada desses
dois anos que eles tiveram juntos de uma
jornada espiritual fantástica porque ele
precisava transfer
o obstaculo E como eles se aproximaram e
também aconteceu uma coisa muito curiosa
uma gatinha linda que morava na Rua
entrou no prédio foi até o salão hoje
Meu sobrinho estava deitado no sofá e
foi falar com ele e isso foi muito lindo
Porque nas meus estudos para os egípcios
os gatos são quem levam a alma pela
eternidade então eu consegui ver Beleza
apesar de tanta dor depois da morte vem
a segunda porrada meio a Rê bordosa que
é o luto o luto é um tiro de escopeta no
coração quando dá para você ver o buraco
do outro lado é quando você
provavelmente vai falar coisas que não
deveria falar mas que ninguém tem
certeza mas fala mesmo assim porque
ninguém sabe o que dizer ninguém está
preparado para esse momento a primeira
coisa que todo mundo fala é meus pêsames
sem saber o que isso quer dizer
O que significa pesar em mim ou seja seu
luto pesa em mim é um fardo por isso que
todo mundo vaza quando as pessoas estão
limitadas e também vai dizer coisas como
pelo menos ele Descansou sendo que a
morte não é um spa todas essas coisas ou
entram por um ouvido e saem pelo outro
ou elas vão machucar mais ainda quem já
tá em carne viva
e o pior ainda vai falar para quem tem
lutado a foi o destino como se o luto
fosse o título de um nome de um filme do
Tom Cruise que que a gente precisa Então
diante de uma pessoa e lotada é
e a gente precisa ser um cobertor nos
dias de frio porque o luto é uma
transição vivida a cada dia sem essa
pessoa de uma vida com essa pessoa para
outra sem essa pessoa a gente precisa
permitir que as Pessoas sintam o que
elas quiserem sentir sem julgamento a
gente precisa da arte da escutatória
escutar sem cortar as frases a gente
precisa entender que essa pessoas vezes
não lembra nem de pagar as contas da luz
e nem te fazer uma torta de palmito no
jantar então a gente pode oferecer essas
coisas e aonde a gente lembra que o luto
é contração e expansão Então tudo bem um
dia ficar muito bem e tudo bem um dia
ficar muito mal é assim que a vida
funciona É assim que as coisas continuam
é mas com o passar do tempo o luto
encontra um lugar de descanso porque a
gente entende que a pessoa que morreu
não é só a morte dela é também tudo que
vivemos juntos que essa pessoa está em
todos os lugares que fizemos o
aniversário juntos festas de natal e de
férias compramos juntos a camiseta do
time de futebol portanto essa pessoa
passa a ser homenageada em todos esses
momentos alegres e felizes da vida e por
todas essas coisas que eu falei acima
agora a gente tem que entender que é
importante Honrar o luto das pessoas por
que em algum momento da nossa vida nós
também teremos que enterrar nossos
mortos
é muito obrigado
E aí
[Aplausos]